we are asked to graph the function y is
equal to negative two point five cosine
of one-third X on the interval 0 to 6 pi
including the endpoints so let me do my
best attempt at graphing that and to
start off I'm going to graph with the
simplest function or the simplest
version of this or the kind of the root
of this which is just cosine of X so let
me just graph and eventually you can
kind of let me just let me graph cosine
of X so this is my y-axis and I want to
have some space here so I can eventually
graph this entire thing so let me so
let's say that this is negative 1 this
is negative 2 this is positive 1 this is
positive 2 and let's say that this right
over here is this right over here is 2
pi 2 pi and then of course that could be
pi right over there now
the first thing I'm going to let me copy
this because I could use it later I
could use it later to graph the whole
thing so so let's start off so I'm just
going to graph y is equal to cosine of X
so when X is equal to 0 and I'm just
going to do it between the interval 0 &
2 pi
obviously it's a periodic function we'll
keep going in the negative and the
positive directions so what happens when
X is equal to 0 what is cosine of X well
cosine of 0 is 1 what about when what
about when X is equal to PI what is
cosine of PI well cosine of PI is
negative 1 cosine of PI is negative 1
and then what's cosine of 2 pi well
that's 1 again we get back we've
completed in a period or we completed an
entire cycle and 2 pi is the period of
cosine of X so this is one cycle right
over here I could keep going if I wanted
to but the whole point
I just wanted to graph this one cycle
between 0 and 2pi now what I want to
think about is what happens to this
graph instead of graphing instead of
graphing y equals cosine of X and
draw some graph paper again instead of
drawing y is equal to cosine of X I'm
going to draw Y is equal to cosine of
1/3 X so the only difference in that and
that is now I'm multiplying the X by 1/3
what's going to happen to the graph over
here how is this going to change instead
of being an X if it's a 1/3 X what's
going to happen over here and now I'm
going to do it over the entire interval
between 0 & 6 pi so let me just make
sure I have enough space so that's 3 PI
4 PI 5 PI and 6 PI what's going to
happen to this graph well there's a
couple of ways to think about it the
easiest might just to be say well to
complete an entire cycle we're going to
we're going to go 1/3 as as fast or
we're going to go 3 times slower or if
you just want to think about the period
here what's the period of cosine of 1/3
X well the period the period is going to
be 2 pi divided by the absolute value of
this coefficient right over here so it's
the absolute value of 1/3 which is just
1/3 so the period is 2 PI over 1/3 which
the same thing as 2 pi times 3 which is
6 pi which is which gels with the
intuition that's going to take what it's
going to take three times as much time
to get whatever we input into the cosine
function to get back to 2 pi because
whatever we take X we're taking 1/3 of
it so instead of we to get to 2 pi you
can't just have x equals 2 pi X now has
to equal 6 pi to get 2 pi input it into
the cosine function so the period is now
6 pi at X is equal to 0 1/3 times 0 is 0
and the cosine of 0 is 1 when X is equal
to 6 pi you have 6 pi divided by 3 is 2
pi cosine of 2 pi is equal to 1 and if
you want to go in between over here we
to go in between we tried pi but over
here we could try 3 pi when X is 3 PI
you have cosine of 1/3 of 3 PI that's
cosine of PI cosine of PI is negative 1
so when X is equal to three PI we have
cosine cosine of 1/3 times 3 bi is
negative 1 so it's going to look
something like this it's going to look
something something like this drawing my
my best attempt best attempt to draw it
so it's going to look something like
this
so you see to go from coast y equals
cosine of X to cut y equals cosine of
1/3 X it essentially stretched out it
stretched out to this function by a by a
factor of three or you can see this
period is three times longer the period
here the period here was pot 2pi period
here was 2pi all right well there's only
one more transformation we need in order
to get to the function that they asking
us about we just have to instead of
having a cosine of 1/3 X we just have to
negative two point five cosine of 1/3 X
so let's try to draw that so let me let
me put my axis here again and let me let
me label it so that's cosine 2 pi 3 pi 4
PI 5 PI and 6 PI and our goal now is to
draw the graph of y is equal to and
we're just doing it over this between 0
& 6 pi here we only did it between 0 & 2
pi here obviously they're they're all
periodic they all keep going on and on
they all keep going on and on but now we
want to graph y is equal to negative two
point five times cosine of 1/3 X so
given this change we're now multiplying
by negative two point five what is going
to be well actually let's think about a
few things
what was the amplitude in the first two
graphs right over here so what was the
amplitude amplitude in these first two
graphs well there's two ways to think
about it you could say the amplitude is
half the difference between the minimum
and the maximum points in either of
these case the minimum is negative one
maximum is one the dip
- half of that is one half of that is
one or you could just say it's the
absolute value of the coefficient here
which is implicitly a 1 and the absolute
value of one is once again one what's
going to be the amplitude for this thing
right over here well the amplitude the
amplitude is going to be the absolute
value of what's multiplying the cosine
function so the amplitude in this case
I'll do it in green the amplitude is
going to be equal to the absolute value
of negative two point five which is
equal to two point five so given that
given that how is multiplying by
negative two point five going to
transform going to transform this graph
right over here well let's think about
it if it was multiplying by just a
positive two point five you would
stretch it out each at each point it
would go it would go up by a factor of
two and a half but it's a negative two
point five so at each point you're going
to stretch it out and then you're going
to flip it over the x-axis so let's do
that so when X was zero you got through
one in this case but now we're going to
multiply that by negative two point five
which means you're going to get to
negative two point five so let me draw a
negative two point five right over there
so that's negative two point five that
would be negative they make it clear
this would be this would be negative
three right over here this would be
positive three so that number right of
there is negative two point five and let
me draw a dotted line there it could
serve to be useful now when when our
function is is it when cosine of
one-third X is zero it doesn't matter
what you multiply it by you're still
going to get zero right over here now
when cosine of one-third X was negative
one which was the case when X is equal
to 3 PI when X is equal to 3 PI what's
going to happen over here well cosine of
1/3 X we see is negative one negative
one times negative two point five is
positive two point five so we're going
to get two positive two point five which
is right
over here we're going to get to positive
2.5 which is right over there and then
when cosine of 1/3 X is equal to zero
doesn't matter what we multiply it by we
get to zero and then finally when cosine
of 1/3 X when X is at 6 PI cosine of 1/3
X is equal to 1 what's that going to be
when you multiply it by negative two
point five what's going to be negative
two point five so we're going to get
back over here so we're ready to draw
our graph it looks something let me do
that magenta color since that's what the
color I wrote this in it will look like
this it will look let me draw I can draw
it as a solid line so it will look like
like that so you saw what happened by by
putting this one-third here it stretched
out the graph it increased the period by
a factor of three and then multiplying
it by negative two point five if you
just multiply it by two point five the
amp you you would have you would just
have the the you just kind of you would
just multiply that out a little bit but
now it's a negative so not only do you
increase the amplitude but you flip it
over so it is indeed the case that the
amplitude here is two point five we very
two point five from our middle position
or you could say that the difference
between the minimum and the maximum is
five so half of that is two point five
but it isn't just multiplying this graph
by two point five if you multiply this
graph by two point five you'd get
something let me be a little neater you
would get something that looked
something like like that but we actually
because we had a negative we had to flip
it over the x-axis and we got this year
so this amplitude is two point five but
it's a flipped over version of this
graph